on va se faire un petit top 5 des vidéos
demande malaise à la télé alors en
cinquième position
c'est un malaise dans l'émission un
dîner presque parfait où un participant
raconte une blague qui va faire un
énorme bide de regarder il trouve que
son hôte ne lui raconte pas assez
l'histoire est bien aussitôt dit
aussitôt fait madame va être servi elia
qui rentre dans le saloon super énervé
un petit cowboy qui rentrent dans le
saloon rentrer dans le coma il fait que
je n'osais pas bon cheval aux bleus il
atteint énorme gaillard qui se lève du
contrat qui lie fait c'est moi pourquoi
fg comme il fait c'est juste pour savoir
quand vous avez mettre la deuxième
couche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le but la terre c'est là qu'ils saillen
blague là pour qu'on fasse la même chose
mon frère habite à l'étagé une devinette
sexy mais et sexiste vas-y super c'est
génial quelle est la différence entre
une femme et une piscine n'ont pas fait
part d'aucune parce que dans les deux
cas ça coûte très cher à l'entretien par
rapport au temps on reste dedans
[Applaudissements]
avant vous allez vous sinon j'adore les
blagues c'est vrai ben ça se voit depuis
les autres vous en avez une autre
peut-être pour vous rattraper
c'est encore ce qui descend de la
montagne je vais avoir à cheval si vous
voulez il va voir il dit merde c'est
pour établir sa pension de retraite voir
si vraiment il a droit à la retraite
il va chez le médecin dit mais j'ai
perdu mes papiers depuis ce pas grave
vous savez rien qu'en touchant voter ton
je peux dire si vous avez atteint l'âge
de la retraite et vous savez droit à une
pension
par contre dell tripote elle touche en
effet c'est bon vous avez votre pension
vous avez l'âge de la retraite et
remonte chez lui dit tu vois chérie ça y
est gelée ma pension te ferais tout ce
qui m'emmerde c'est qu'il avait touché
50 centimètres plus bas de 20 plus avait
une pension d'invalidité
[Applaudissements]
ils vont organiser des randonnées dans
les séquences malaise
bien sûr et c'est important
ah ça roule pas toujours bien oui voilà
un grain de sable dans la machine ou que
la machine à vous êtes le grain de sable
on passe à présent à la 4e place des
malaises avec gérard holtz qui profite
que le tour de france passe en belgique
dans la ville de putte pour faire une
vanne qui ne va pas faire rire les
autres commentateurs
regardez en arrivant dans cette ville
belge j'ai je dois avouer que je n'ai
jamais vu autant de fils de putte sur le
bord de la route
bon et gérard gouzes appaloosa par ce
genre de choses
[Applaudissements]
j'avais entendu de ma vie c'était le bec
minutes à bord ils ont dû dire je la
trouve je ne fais pas ça passe mais bon
jamais un jeune homo mais là c'est
vraiment l'un des fils de [ __ ] jeunes
montrent maintenant au jeu de mot avec
plus tôt l'appareil n'ont plus bas ça ça
pullule pas au troisième position il
s'agit d'un moment dans l'émission la
quotidienne sur france 5 où un
chroniqueur frappe et gérard michel qui
était intégrée
julien tomber dans sans aucun doute fait
une remarque une remarque qui va être
très mal compris se regarde comme romain
qui a dit oui au regard des prévisions
sur les bonbons et qui voudraient un
colis de bonbons sont à 13 5 millions
servent à s'arranger
c'est bien parce que vous avez huit ans
c'est incroyable d'avoir huit ans est de
regarder la quotidienne
mais bon c'est nos côtes et suzuki- je
vais donner mon adresse une peur la
tactique l'on voulait pas du tout dire
ça en deuxième position il s'agit d'une
fille dans l'émission tellement vrai qui
a toujours envie de faire l'amour
alors elle discute avec une copine have
a party à voir son copain
regardez bien la tête de sa copine qui
restent seuls regarde au bout de 30
minutes de mensonges marion ne tient
plus comme à chaque fois elle fait mine
de devoir parler à tristan pour
s'échapper et assouvir son désir
attentif quand surviennent
tiens ce prêt je te parle en urgence par
dorine de riz
[Musique]
je suis
il s'appelle a peiné en première
position bien sûr loin devant tous les
autres
ce sont les policiers dans sept à huit
qui essaye de faire de la barque pendant
les inondations
on leur fait des bisous regardez mais
contrairement aux apparences le courant
est très fort leur mission va s'avérer
plus difficile que prévu du coup
[Applaudissements]